[Musica]
d
io ha le mani in basso
questa frase nella consegnata qualche
anno fa una bambina di 10 anni che dopo
avermi sentito parlare in un modo un po
particolare mi ha detto simona non è
vero che non hai le mani
tu hai le mani in basso e da quel giorno
io quella frase me la sono presa tenuta
stretta e portata con me ad incontrare
come voi oggi certo non da questo posto
meraviglioso ma l'ho voluta portare fin
quassù in realtà voglio fare un'altra
cosa
da quassù se voi me lo permettete anzi
se la montagna
me lo permette voglio gridare questa
frase io ho le mani in basso e lo voglio
gridare
da qui perché l'universo lo possa
ascoltare perché tutti noi un giorno
senza avere paura possiamo dire che noi
siamo quello che siamo
che noi non siamo né superiori e
inferiori a qualcun altro
ma siamo semplicemente noi stessi con le
nostre diversità con le nostre
particolarità e quindi questa montagna e
voi oggi accogliete la mia particolarità
come io accolgo la vostra
pensate che in questa emergenza in
realtà noi siamo qui senza covip non ci
saremo quindi dalle cose difficili
nascono le cose più belle per me non
avere le braccia significa avere le mani
in basso ma voi vi chiederete cosa
significa avere nevano in basso
adesso ve lo spiego perché in realtà ora
voi vedete un corpo che si se cercate
bene vigini giro non ci sono trucchi non
ci sono e per ora farò qualcosa che vi
farà capire cosa significa questa
favolosa frase che quella bimba mi ha
detto se io ora mi siedo guardate la
ballerina si è seduta bene e mi tolgo le
scarpe
non pensate che io sia maleducata ma in
realtà
un po sì ma devo essere maleducata per
presentarvi loro ciao io sono simona e
queste sono le mie mani in basso piacere
ve lo presento loro sono piedi ma sono
anche mani anzi in realtà per il 90 per
cento della giornata loro fanno le mani
e quindi io ora inizierò a gesticolare
se non cade vado giù dalla montagna per
un po per questi spero otto minuti di
non sgarrare
e voi fra un po probabilmente riuscirete
a guardare non a quello che mi manca ma
quello che ho e forse a dire magari lo
diremo tutti insieme alla fine quello
che ha detto quella bambina che non è
vero che io non ho le mani
sì se proprio vogliamo essere
puntigliosi ma ho le mani in basso
perché loro sono davvero le mie mani e
io le amo le ringrazio ogni giorno
perché ogni giorno mi permettono non
solo di sentire il terreno duro e cui è
bello duro gli permettono di danzare
quindi di dare forma alla mia danza ti
permettono però poi di fare tutto quello
che le persone fanno quei loro con le
loro mani di mangiare di scrivere di
truccarmi ma mi permettono anche di
accarezzare il mio volto e di
accarezzare le persone a cui voglio bene
e allora le mani sono un tramite il
nostro corpo e un tramite per arrivare
agli altri è qualcosa che serve a noi ma
che arriva a comunicare con le altre
persone
e allora ogni giorno gredig dico grazie
a loro perché davvero sono speciale a
volte li chiedo davvero tanto credetemi
a volte li devo ringraziare in maniera
incredibile perché faccio cose che voi
umani non potrete mai immaginare e loro
in realtà mi aiutano a trasformarle in
realtà trasformarlo in qualcosa di
concreto
dalle piccole cose alle cose più grandi
e attraverso di loro gli ho scoperto
qual è il vero senso della mia vita in
realtà pensa quando ero bambina io
dentro la pancia de ronde la mia mamma
dice posizione podalica quindi spingevo
con i piedi
in realtà simbolicamente io ho sempre
pensato che quella posizione fin da
quando ero nella pancia della mamma
significava che volevo dare un input
volevo dire dovete guardare ai miei
piedi
loro sono il segreto della mia vita
naturalmente dopo un cesareo quando sono
uscita fuori all'ospedale di milano
tutto anno che pensato tranne quello
naturalmente c'è stato come potete
immaginare una grande disperazione prima
da parte dei medici da parte della
famiglia della mia famiglia che però poi
ha capito che dovevano spostare il focus
spostare la prospettiva quindi
focalizzarsi su ciò che avevo e li
quell'input gliel'ho dato io fin da
bambina dentro la culla che muovevo i
miei piedi cercando di prendere una
grande palla rossa messa sulla mia testa
ma come tutti i bambini non la calciavo
a un certo punto loro hanno visto che io
aprivo i miei piedi in questo modo quasi
un fiore che sboccia cercavo proprio di
afferrarla
stavo dicendo loro io ha le mani in
basso non guardate a quello che mi manca
guardate a quello che c'è iniziamo la
nostra vita da un'altra prospettiva
difficile sicuramente diversa da tutti
quelli degli altri ma possibile
e solo un ingrediente ci ha aiutato in
questo percorso e si chiama amore
l'amore aiutato loro aiutato noi a
scoprire che avere le mani in basso
era il segreto no loro pensa della mia
della nostra vita
e allora ha finito mi alzo perché lo
voglio gridare con voi state voi non ce
le avete le mani in basso le cose sono
un po più su ma provate a sentirvi unici
non quanto sono io quanto siamo ognuno
di noi
al mio tre 123 io ha le mani in basso
grazie
[Musica]